So what exactly is Core Data?
Core data is essentially
a framework to help you manage
the model part of your app.
You recall that the model view
controller design patterns splits
your app up into three parts.
And that the model part is what
deals with the important tangible
essential pieces of the app.
Core data gives us a way to
manage these important pieces and
gives them the title managed objects.
What does managing these objects entail?
It includes everything from changing
them, tracking them, persisting them,
to managing their relationships and
more.
Let's look at an overview of the core
data architecture to see how this works.
There are several main components
to become familiar with, and
we've already somewhat
touched on two of them.
The managed object model,
also referred to as the data model,
is basically the physical representation
of the model we just spoke of.
It exists in XCode as a special
kind of graphic file,
similar to a storyboard file, but
with different purpose and capabilities.
The managed object model is what is used
to specify the classes and relationships
that will be managed within your app and
is therefore also what the tables and
rows of your app's SQL-like
database will be generated from.
Much like how interface builder
automates a storyboard file,
core data automates
a managed object model file.
Managed objects are those important
fundamental pieces we spoke of earlier.
A character in a game app and
event in a calendar app.
There would specified by
your object model and
what are actually responsible for
most of core data's magic,
see while they look like regular swift
objects they have a substantial twist.
Unlike any object we've seen thus far,
they save the contents of their
properties to a database file.
Core data actually hides
this complexity from us, so
we don't have to worry about it,
which is why we refer to it as magic.
Every single object of your model will
be a subclass of NSManagedObject.
The managed object context or
the context is where most
of the action happens.
This object,
an instance of NSManagedObjectContext
is helpful to imagine as a place.
The context is where your managed
objects live until they're saved to disk
and when nearly every core
data operation takes place.
Want to create an object you need
a context in which it will live.
Want to delete an object?
Ask the context.
Want to save?
Again ask the context.
To find out who and
what is living inside the context,
a fetch request is needed.
A fetch request is a search
of the context for
a certain type of managed object.
It can specify the type of
managed object, a filter, and
how the resulting objects
should be sorted.
All of the pieces of core today
that we've discussed thus far,
have belonged to the model layer.
This next piece, the fetch results
controller works in part to control how
the data from the fetch requests
will be displayed in the view and
is thus part of the controller layer.
A fetch results controller takes
fetch request runs the search and
helps display the results
in a table view, or
with a little extra work on
our part a collection view.
The most basic task a controller must
perform is to keep the model and
view in sync.
An NS Fetch results controller
does precisely this.
If the objects returned by
the fetch request ever change,
the fetch results controller
automatically updates the table view.
At the lower level, Core Data relies
on what's called persistent stores, or
stores for short.
Stores like the name implies
are were managed objects
actually get stored when saved to disk.
They can be thought of as
database data files and
can exist in several types namely XML,
binary format and SQLite.
The latter being the most common and
also the one will be using.
Note that you can have more than one
store or type of store in a given app.
Also at the lower level is the last
piece we're going to talk about for now.
The persistent Store Coordinator.
This object allows you to
have multiple stores and
keep the rest of your
app from knowing it.
But for the most part,
persistence stores and
their coordinators are not something
you have to worry about too much.
These classes when put together make
up what's called the Core Data Stack.